if you really want to solve a
complicated problem maybe you try to
solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it when do you quit organize your brain
when you sleep at least to the degree
that you can organize it and you can
often be more solid or more doubtful
about a decision
if you sleep on it
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person i'm not but when you
start your day off with a powerful
routine that inspires you like watch one
of these videos it will change your life
so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee know that i
believe in you and get ready for a shot
of espresso from jordan peterson
[Music]
i wake up every morning
you know if you really want to solve a
complicated problem maybe you try to
solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs this is
something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail
at
producing their creative product and
monetizing it right so your default
position if you're a creative person is
you're going to fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's j
and it's hard to
present it to the market at the right
time and it's hard to market it like
those things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and eventually if they're fortunate
one of their ideas happens to hit
the right place at the right time and so
that's also
darwinian in some sense you know you're
creating all these little enterprises
that are sort of alive
they're they're run by people after all
and even if your idea is good that
doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so
this is partly why persistence and
that's part of conscientiousness is so
useful it's like you know what are they
safe if at first you failed then try try
again and um and that would probably
mean try something different rather than
the same thing
but
persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and and you need to know that the
baseline is failure
you know it's important because
otherwise you'll blame that on yourself
when do you quit
you quit when you don't love it anymore
you quit when the process isn't fun for
you anymore you quit when the thing
you're doing starts to feel like a job
but if you still love it
you have to keep going you have to find
another way you have to show up again
today because if you don't you will
spend the rest of your life
regretting wondering what could have
happened if you just didn't quit today
the worst day of my life was when i was
20 and i and i quit on my business
partner i told him i quit i can't do
this anymore
i need to find something that makes me
feel valuable as a human of all the
things that happened to me in my life
you know this has been a lot of negative
situation that we've all faced but you
know
from uh breaking my neck and
struggling a lot you know the thing that
just the the worst the worst day of my
life was when i told my business partner
that i quit because it's a self-identity
thing i couldn't believe that i had said
those words on something i cared about
it's not about
something that you weren't trying like
oh i'll quit on this one thing that i
never really cared about anyway we don't
care about that it's when you care about
it when you've been putting everything
you've got into it and you're still not
getting results and and you quit for
that reason
that stuff that will eat you up and so
it was the worst day of my life because
i couldn't imagine me
saying it
and i was so lost and so insecure and so
unsure of just what to do next
but i know that i i knew that i wanted
to
feel valuable as a human again and so
it couldn't i couldn't keep going this
way
but i woke up the next day and i
realized i can't quit yet i can't quit
now i haven't given everything i don't
want to
i don't want to be an old man at 40 you
know i'm 41 now i don't want to be an
old man at 40 and look back in my life
and regret it and just know that i had a
chance to do something special and i
quit a little bit too soon
so if you still love the thing that
you're doing
you can't quit
not yet
so how do you still get the momentum how
do you still get the motivation how do
you still keep going i got three tips
for you that i think will help
number one is find a different way to
stand so this was something that really
saved me that that came from oprah
winfrey
she said
you
i don't remember the exact quote now but
something about finding a different way
to stand
you have to find a different way to stay
and it just really stuck with me to say
okay
what i'm doing
may not be working yet but still will
have value it's it's really hard to have
that belief that everything i've done to
this point may not have worked but but
if i keep going we'll have value i just
need to find a different way to stand i
just need to find a different way of
doing it i just need to find another
path there's another way around it that
i just haven't seen yet and the path for
me was modeling success
that's the thing that saved me so i i
said okay i've i feel like i've done
everything i feel like i've tried every
route and and i'm i'm hopeless and
helpless and have no no path forward
but seeing opus quote find a different
way to stand
just gave me
the hope
and resourcefulness to say okay i'm
going to find another way to do it so if
you still love doing it
and it just hasn't worked out yet step
number one is find a different way to
stand
step number two
is find someone who's done it to model
success i think one of the biggest
challenges we face as entrepreneurs is
we feel like we have to come up with all
the ideas ourselves you gotta come with
every genius idea yourself that's
certainly what i felt at least when i
started my first business that i had to
come up with all the ideas i was almost
cheating to look what other people were
doing but no it's not you need to you
need to model success you need to find
the people who've done in any area of
your life in your business and your
relationships and your health find the
person who's done the thing that you're
trying to do and then go study them go
model them go look at what worked for
them and how you can then maybe apply it
to your situation and it won't take you
100 of the way
but it takes you eighty percent of the
way
every time i've learned a strategy from
somebody
whether it's jordan peterson or oprah or
bill gates or warren buffett or whoever
i've learned the strategy from them
and i apply it exactly to my life it
doesn't work out
because it's not the exact same
situation and they're not me but it
takes me 80 percent of the way
i then just have to make
some tweaks and some adjustments to make
it work for me and that always speeds up
my path and it's what i've been doing
ever since what i've been teaching ever
since
the fastest way to shortcut your path to
success is to model somebody who's
already done it
look back at how they got started and
how did they overcome those initial
barriers and then how can you apply that
to your life so for me it was looking at
bill gates how he started microsoft he
had a software company i had a software
company looked at his success modeled it
and suddenly i started to have some
results finally
finally that first check that came in
for 13 and a half thousand dollars man
that felt good
not that it was i mean it doesn't seem
like a lot of money i guess now but to
me back then that was that was
man that was everything and more
important it gave some kind of hope some
kind of motivation just some kind of
traction momentum something was finally
working finally working after all the
things i tried that didn't work
something finally was paying off
and so modern success is is going to be
your fastest way to get there and then
step number three is just to change up
your environment
when you are around the people who are
doing the thing that you want to do it
just gives you more hope that it's
possible
it gives you more belief that it can
work if you're around people who just
gave up on their dreams who are taking
the safe path out taking the safe route
telling you to go do something else you
know go go become a xyz because that's
what they became
if that's all you're around people who
are who are telling you that you can't
do it and telling you that your ideas
suck
it really becomes difficult to
stay motivated to stay on it it takes a
incredible level of self commitment to
make that happen and it's totally
possible
but
what's even better is to be around the
people who are doing it so on your down
days they pull you up and that could be
having a mentor or coach that could be
hanging out with with people who are you
know in your life who are
making you believe in yourself that
could be joining a group like like my
movement makers program we where you're
around people who are all doing
something trying something building a
movement encouraging each other who lift
each other up when the when they're
feeling down and feel like hope's not
possible or it could just be through
videos and books and podcasts and and
the things that you do in your daily
habits and routines look at
everything that you're doing in your
routine look at the people that you're
hanging out with look at the information
that you're feeding into your brain
and how much of it
when you leave it you feel better about
yourself how many videos are you
watching that when you stop it when you
leave the video the video is over you
feel better about yourself you feel more
confident more hopeful more belief more
momentum
how many people that when you leave
their presence when you stop talking to
them right you say goodbye you feel more
positive more inspired more ready to go
home and go after your goals versus the
things that make you feel like
it's not gonna happen it's not possible
you feel negative you you've lost energy
compared to when you went in and the
more you can flip that to be more around
the people the resources the energy that
fill you up even if it's just virtually
you have nobody in your life but evan i
have nobody in my life like that okay
not yet first of all right you have
nobody in your life yet that's like that
but you still have me you still have
these videos you still have other
channels and other podcasts you can go
and subscribe to and listen to that if
you're around consistently we'll shift
you forward we'll pull you forward we'll
give you more momentum we'll give you
that actual little bit of
encouragement and commitment for when
you feel like quitting when you feel
like the world's against you when you
feel like it's just not happening not
yet not now not for you
that they lift you up that they give you
that extra little oomph to go one more
day one more day one more day
and then soon enough that one day
something happens
and you look back and you realize man am
i ever grateful that i kept going
if you still love what you're doing
if you still love the process you love
the work it doesn't feel like a job
showing up
you have to keep going you have to you
have to you have to you have to
because otherwise you're going to regret
it and i don't want that for you
i don't want you to to
be an old man or old woman and look back
and say back here back back at this
moment right now present day i could
have done something
i could have played bigger i could have
kept going
i could have made my mark and could have
my impact you could have been a
contender
but you didn't
because you were afraid
and you quit maybe one day too soon
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated you have a 35 percent chance
of actually doing something making a
change that's what the sign says 35
percent that's not on that believe
nation but when you watch a video you
get motivated and then you create a
specific plan of action for what you're
going to do it jumps to 91 chance of you
following through and when you commit
publicly like put it in the comments
below what your plan is it jumps to 95
so believe nation your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
with you also if you want to have more
self love and self
i've designed a special free training to
help you get it the science says it can
take up to 254 days of consecutive
action to build a habit and if you want
to build the habit of self-confidence
and self-belief check it out in the
description below there's a link that
will send you a video every day for the
next 254 days 100 free to shift your
confidence forward the link to join is
in the description below if you're going
to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about well you have to treat
yourself like you matter because if you
don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful oh no
you're okay you should feel good about
yourself like you're you're fine the way
you are it's like you think well that's
a calming message for people you have to
negotiate until you come to the best
solution that can be negotiated which
isn't necessarily a perfect solution but
it might be the best one that can be
done and then you have to stick with it
until the next negotiation and
if you get upset during the negotiations
which you likely will because these are
difficult topics how to divide up
responsibilities in the house and people
get mad because they feel they've been
taken advantage of or aren't being
listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or
people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got
the balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
um maybe sometimes when you're
negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
going to agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision make it schedule and stick to
it okay so what's the rule with the
schedule
it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i have to do this then i have to do this
then i have to do this you know and then
i just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that i have
to do it's like wrong
set the schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that than at the beginning of the
day right because that's a
day if you have a bunch of those in a
row you just dig you know you dig
yourself a hole and then you bury
yourself in it's like sorry that's just
not a good strategy it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well i've got
these responsibilities i have to
schedule the things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who was working for you it's like okay
you gotta work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for god's sake or because
you're gonna hit that position where
things start to loop back positively and
spiral you upward you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a mode of
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the depth by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something i mean you can think
about this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient 20
times more efficient that's the pareto
distribution you have no idea how
efficient efficient people get it's
completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's 9 billion 7 billion people in
the world we're going to peak at about 9
billion by the way and then it'll
decline rapidly but seven billion people
in the world and who are you you're just
one little dust mote among that seven
billion and so it really doesn't matter
what you do or don't do but that's
simply not the case it's the wrong model
because you're at the center of a
network you're a node in a network of
course that's even more true now that we
have social media you'll you'll know a
thousand people at least over the course
of your life and they'll know a thousand
people each and that puts you one person
away from a million and two persons away
from a billion and so that's how you're
connected and the things you do they're
like dropping a stone in a pond the
ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really asked yourself would you be
so sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society
and if enough people do that then it's
hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century the next best predictor of
lifetime success is conscientiousness
well so and of tho of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes i think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that and basically it does a
situational analysis of it helps you do
a situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis i would
say and so the questions are something
like well
all right you're going to have to put
some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in neuroticism you want security
okay so those are all sources of
potential motivation that you could draw
on that you could tailor to your own you
know your own personality but then there
are dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to auger down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the micro processes become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want you want to
specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer that has to be because you've
determined by some
means that it's worthwhile
and then the next question might be well
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be well you could
consult your own temperament and the
other would be well you kind of look at
how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the sub-components of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once but once you set up that that
goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
use everything you learn as a means of
building that person that you want to be
and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so if
i was saying well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious okay
number one specify your goals because
how are you going to hit something if
you don't know what it is that isn't
going to happen and often people won't
specify their goals too because they
don't like to specify conditions for
failure so if you keep yourself all
vague and foggy
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful so i'll keep myself blind about
when i fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so
i would recommend that you don't let
that happen so that's willful blindness
right you could have known but you chose
not to okay so once you get your goal
structure set up you think okay if i
could have this life it looks like that
might be worth living despite the fact
that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort i started to
pay very careful attention to
what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas
and there was another part that was
watching that part like
just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was
well people have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like
well which of those two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know was that me or was the part
that was going about my normal verbal
business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i'd
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as a coherence between the
the the spiritual or the or the abstract
and the physical that the two things
were aligned and and there's a lot of
idea of alignment in in psychoanalytic
and clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen this circumambulation
that jung talked about was this
continual
will return to this this continual
circling in some sense of who you could
be you might notice for example that
there are themes in your life you know
when you go back across your experiences
you see you kind of have your typical
experience that sort of repeats itself
and there might be variation on it like
a musical theme but it's it's like
you're circling yourself and getting
closer to yourself as you move across
time that's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second we'll go back
to it okay so imagine that something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning and you decide well first
of all you're paralyzed you think well
how do i know if i should pursue that
it's probably a stupid idea and the
proper response to that is you're right
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all ideas are stupid
and so the the probability that as you
move forward on your adventure that
you're going to get it right the first
time is zero it's just not going to
happen and so then you might think well
maybe i'll just wait around until i get
the right idea and which people do right
so they're like 40 year old 13 year olds
which is not a good idea so they wait
around until it's waiting for godot
until they finally got it right but the
problem is you're too stupid to know
when you've got it right so waiting
around isn't going to help because even
if it the perfect opportunity manifested
itself to you in your incomplete form
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero
you might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's
nietzsche called that a will to
stupidity which i really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps
on your
pathway to destiny and you can assume
that you're going to do it badly and
that's really useful because you don't
have to beat yourself up it's pretty
easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all so why
is that well okay so you you start your
path and you think that you're heading
you know towards your star
and so you go in that direction and
then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were it's it's
going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you and so then you have to
take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
i mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than
you would be if you just stayed where
you were waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress the
degree of overshooting starts to decline
right and that we know that there's
nothing hypothetical about that as you
learn a new skill like even to play play
a song on the piano for example you
overshoot madly you're making all sorts
of mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
they they disappear so anyways
the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean you have to stop and thank
god for that that's a really useful
thing
and the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean that you can't learn
and so you can posit an ideal and you're
going to be wrong about it but it
doesn't matter because what you're right
about is positing the ideal moving
towards it if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you going to do that's perfect so
it doesn't matter that it's imperf
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as i'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that my question is
again you're one of the best
communicators that i've ever listened to
if i could be
half as good
at you or at communicating as you are
i would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things is
it helps to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
ten times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side
well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when i talk to a
group i always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell
if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they give you feedback about how
you're doing and so one thing is to to
have something to say
yeah
but the next thing is pay attention to
who you're talking to
because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know
and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but at first but on first sight
you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about you're actually engaged
in a conversation with an audience even
if they're not
talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or
and you can you can pull all that in and
and and use it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well i can
buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate i don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter i mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so
the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges i think
i don't know if they've forgotten it but
they don't do a very good job of
marketing it's like what's the use of a
bachelor's degree in bachelor of arts
it's like well
you can think
you can write
you can speak
you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that i've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice i like this one and i think i
mean this is very clearly what you do be
precise in your speech
so in in genesis one of the things god
has adam do first so god makes the world
by speaking okay so that's the first
thing to think about
you're supposed to think like
in a sophisticated way about this the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between
communication and the structure of being
it's part of the role that consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so
god has adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now
they're more implicit that's another you
know here's here's an example let's say
that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why
it's unnameable is it real well yeah
it's manifesting itself in like a
physiological discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing
right and then that's a horrible thing
it's like a little poisonous thing but
it's not a whole
foggy cloud of potential poison it's
like this little sharp poison thing and
then you think okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
precision that specifies and like so
this is a little bit of the voldemort
effect right if since you're a harry
potter guy they wouldn't name them right
this is a problem we've got to name them
first oh yeah you've got to name them
first absolutely because the unnamable
is far more terrifying than the
name-able
you see that in there was this great
blair witch project terrifying movie oh
it was kind of scary
well it's unnamed
there's nothing terrible happens in that
movie it's all the unnamable it's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and
no matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put monsters everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you you're the
loser instantly if it's so terrifying
that you cannot face it with bill c-16
that i wouldn't speak the language of
the radical leftists because i don't
think that that language should define
the game but let's say it does
so here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're going to
view the world
okay now the leftists say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right wingers the radical right
wingers look at that and they say
oh i see so the game is ethnic identity
is it
it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and i'm in my tribe
i'm not going to get all guilty and lose
i'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics spectrum
am i going to fall in do i want to go
with uh do i want to
go
do i want to be driven primarily by
compassion and
am i going to accept guilt for my
historical privilege so that's one
possibility and then i'm the oppressor
i'm the member of the oppressor group or
am i going to say no to hell with that
i'm just going to play to win well then
i'm going to go to the right it's like
well my sense is how about we don't play
either of those games and the reason we
shouldn't play them is
well the soviets played the left wing
game and like killed
who knows how many tens of millions of
people you can't even count it
accurately the estimates range from 20
to 100 million those are pretty big
error bars and the maoists maybe a
hundred million certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well
then there's the nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like what do we want to
play that game
see what i've been trying to do really
what i've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so i have a
book rule in there says set your house
in perfect order before you criticize
the world and it's a
very dark chapter about the motivations
of the columbine high school killers and
this other guy named carl panzram who is
a serial rapist and arsonist and
murderer and these he wrote an
autobiography and the columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful
terrible
and
well i'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim
because we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well everyone's a
victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse
that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly i got
attracted to christian imagery at least
in part
because there's an idea in christianity
that you should pick up your god cross
and like walk up the hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence
that's the right answer it's the right
answer because the rest of it is
tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
to get all tribal again the more radical
the necessary change the more pain that
accompanies it like the more opportunity
as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out
and so the fact that people flee from
that is hardly surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better
the better
idea is to eat a little poison every day
so that you don't have to overdose in a
month it's something like that
and it is the case that i think because
you don't you aren't forced to first of
all you don't learn unless you're forced
to learn i know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that
speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out
it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning
and there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable and so every
chance you get to grab something new
that will help you along your way you
should take it as fast as you can
but you have to have a very
tragic
i would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and
that makes you desperate enough to learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though
your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the
if you being eaten wasn't a real
possibility
it wouldn't be a real fight
and so you see people like i've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
i had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything
at her disposal to do so and i
strategized with him for about three
years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much he got backed into a corner
so hard that i didn't know how to help
him anymore
so
i would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did
manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say he did manage to
establish what i think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got
enough out of what he did to justify it
even though
the whole landscape was pretty
awful
i think that
not lying is your best bet
but
life is hard and people get run over and
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to emerge in any obvious sense
triumphant
but
if you take the alternative path path
especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it and that's
something you know i know you stated in
the last um
uh
lecture that the importance for setting
aims in life and um
to kind of have goals to
work towards right so my question was um
where do you how do you do that if you
don't know where you want to go because
that's kind of where i got stuck on your
your future authoring program because
okay that's that's a good question
that's a really good question so there's
this notion in the old testament that
morality is
following a sequence of prohibitions
there's a bunch of bad things you
shouldn't do and then basically you're
good enough
and and and i think there's wisdom in
that i think that's kind of where
children start right you
i mean i love children and all that but
they're they're they're crazy little
creatures and they need to be you know
civilized and
partly what you do is you you lay
prohibitions on them and
mostly what you're trying to do is lay
prohibitions on them
for the behaviors that if they
manifested would make their life
miserable so this is why this thing that
i've said to people has become this
crazy internet meme but that's to clean
up your room
and which which is a lot better and more
useful than people think it's a lot
harder too but the the thing the first
thing you do i think and i learned this
in part from solzhenitsyn when he was
trying to iron out his soul when he was
in the gulag because he was trying to
figure out how he got there how he
contributed to how he got there you know
not stella and hitler even though they
were kind of to blame you know but
he was much he could do about that i
think what you have to do and this is
part of humility is you have to look
around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like
your room put it in order because the
thing is it isn't exactly so important
that your room is in order although it
is what's important is that you learn
how to distinguish between chaos and
order and to be able to act in a manner
that produces order and i think you can
you can do something as simple as just
sit on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things i could do
today so that
tomorrow morning is slightly better than
this morning was at least or at least
i'm not falling behind and those will
usually be it's like having to eat a
toad in the morning right it's like it's
not going to be something you want to do
there'll be things you're trying to
avoid they're snakes essentially but if
you ask yourself like you're asking
someone which i think is a form of
prayer if you ask yourself instead of
telling yourself you know what is it
that i could do to set things more right
today
that i would actually do it's usually
some small thing because you're not that
disciplined you know then you can go do
it
and then you you put the world together
a little more when you do that
and that spreads out but you also put
your you also construct yourself into
something that's better able to
call order forth from chaos and that
makes you just incrementally stronger
and then the next day you can maybe take
on a slightly larger task and like you
get the benefit of compound interest if
you do that it's a tremendously powerful
technique and i think if you do that
at some point instead of just having to
fix things up that are not good you'll
start to get a glimmer of the positive
things that you could do
you know
the positive things that you could do
that would actually constitute a vision
and that that's what i would recommend
you'll learn that you can you're
actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
over protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity
you know so maybe you're a kid in the
playground right and you're having some
trouble with other kids and you know in
the back of your mind i should deal this
with deal with this myself but you go
and tell your mom and get her to
intervene and you know that that's not
right you know that you're breaking the
social contract but it's easier and so
that's what you do you run off to an
authority figure and hide behind the
great father right roughly speaking well
the problem with that is you don't learn
how to do it yourself so then you have
to relearn it painfully when you're 40.
so then you take people out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from 1 to 10.
so 10 is
make a list of 10 things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number 10. so we'll
start with that okay well i'm afraid of
elevators okay well let's let's look at
a picture of an elevator let's have you
imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially and
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
ten times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in what's no longer the
elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that and then
you're met much more
together much more confident and that's
often one of the things that often
happens in situations like that i've
seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up to people around them in a
way they never did before because they
wouldn't stand up for themselves before
because they weren't willing
to undermine the protection bee i had a
plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and i
was going to test the joints they're
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and i said i told him i
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and i thought yeah that's
okay how about if i test them so i went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to like
half an hour later i had two inches of
water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a trades person it's a bloody
reliable honorable uh forthright
productive way of making a living and
there is a hell of a lot of difference
between a working man who knows what
he's doing and one who doesn't both in
terms of skill and ethics right and you
work with someone who knows what they're
doing it's a bloody pleasure they tell
you what they're going to do they tell
you how much it will cost they go and do
it it works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of
egalitarian egalitarianism and equity
and they fail to recognize completely
that there are differences in rank
between people it's not such a terrible
thing man maybe you wouldn't be a great
lawyer like it's certainly possible most
people aren't but that doesn't mean
there isn't something you could be great
at there's lots of hierarchies to
attempt to climb and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
what are you going to do if you don't
try to aim for the top you know flap
about uselessly and whine about your
life it's not helpful it'll just make
you miserable you're not reliable to
anyone you can't help out in a crisis
it's like so you tell young people and
this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there and
make something of yourself for god's
sake be an honest person and work and
get to the top of whatever it is that
you want to get to the top of you know
and and and
and stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard a month
ago a month and a half i used to teach
there and i talked to a bunch of
students you know and i told them it's
not easy to get into harvard you know
like you're a valedictorian if you're at
harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am i saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so i told them what i just told you
it's like here you are at harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something
make the world that put you here happy
that you were put there in that great
institution you know and they came up to
me afterwards and said god i wish
someone would have told us that when we
were in our first year it's like
why didn't someone tell them that for
god's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest university in the world is it
so difficult to figure that out if you
want more inspiration morning videos
they're not on this channel anymore i
have a dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe and i'll see
you there